all right people all right a second here
um young people are cut so I ask you it
yes like a [ __ ] [ __ ] episodes yeah
and I'm like it's kind of evil the
pizzas in the oven let's go then
okay so here it is Chapter two how a
very good action and gameplay so far oh
sorry
the cab is everyday then talk to me
about cold oh yeah good to smack that
booty hey dude I am sorry I'm so hurt oh
[ __ ] I just got slapped yeah that [ __ ]
great Oh Kyle so since you're pretty
much on your own
mr. plan uh take over she plays it so
good thank you
my plan is working basic please milk me
save that [ __ ] no sir my skip my
tariffs quickie as hell that guys like
okay maybe singing again
mm-hmm yeah that's ants it's kind of oh
what about the whole thing with that
pregnant lady [ __ ] around her
you're like typical tell everyone all
right here's the baby yeah oh god gotta
go
they're walking that had a pet up like
that girl all right just be Italian
booty
I honestly let's have that calf muscle
how there yet staring a bullet
you know the mastery don't die I have
another okay people love doing this yeah
let him find out you know I kick in
trouble if he tells me but there you
know so I hole up there what the [ __ ]
that's a [ __ ] knee that's the worst
part you can't jack off I know it that's
what I would do if I got bit up to jack
off until I turn it and that I won't be
I can puck he said his army with the
dignity okay
hello propane oh those are faint a goes
like damn yeah yeah my backpack maybe
show some drawings I did wear my
coloring book yeah yeah he has my
[ __ ] water here
okay look at truck doors they look dirty
okay that's weird
um we can hack saw that [ __ ] getting it
take these car keys so I can use the car
keys let me take the hacksaw though make
sure it's just box real quick here well
he's like he's sucking [ __ ] oh okay
we wait the winning any of this [ __ ] the
[ __ ] whatever the car keys idea okay
he's if he he's a good current he's
metamorphosized crimp the saw [ __ ] cut
the saw you got it off the head you got
no choice oh [ __ ] he got a lot of makeup
on me what a [ __ ] weird guy
why do you put all that makeup on what
we need
about five years old you know I just
tell that you know thank you
you know remember that before like what
like an hour gonna have to make a break
for it I'll buy you some time
yes
all right I'll try well like my daddy
used to say let's get this over with
uh-huh this guy is all sorts of [ __ ]
up Liam leave up leo
[Music]
yeah okay
they ate him pretty fast episode 2 a
house divided I thought we were playing
it was do that funny what happened where
are they what do you mean by help the
stream we gotta go just hold on [ __ ] her
in the belly Clementine
can can you please walk Sarah she's
upstairs just distract her and don't
tell her anything I'll take care of her
you can trust me thank you you'll be
safe inside just don't open the doors
for anything we'll be back soon and
thank you
okay let me take that pitch upstairs
there should be taking pictures of
already read do a lot of time actually
[Music]
okay
what chef chef a chance to [ __ ] okay
I'm usually bad with bajalia no shows
yeah
do you want to see what I found yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah honey the gun oh god
yeah yeah what if I have to use one okay
but it's not a toy
I know first remember it's just a thing
what does that mean mmm I don't know I
thought it'd be heavier okay
why do I do the most important thing is
when you go to shoot take a breath
before you pull the trigger [ __ ] [ __ ]
CEQA hey sure yeah I guess it sounds
Luke take a duck but I've actually think
left yeah this isn't good this is not
good
all right here's a pop-out scare mm-hmm
papa scary yeah it's not good it's way
too quiet there [ __ ] gonna go down yeah
like like oh god she's like oh [ __ ] like
you're what did I do
busy
go and find somewhere to hide yeah bet I
am
hello I need to lock this door hello
there get out of here now is that how
your dad taught you to greet a neighbor
I have a gun a smart girl I would do but
I'm not a bad guy promise you get out of
here what's your name is there anyone
else you don't usually see cabins this
big out here we have a big group lots Oh
how big dozens they'll be back soon and
they left you here alone he must trust
you yeah cut to the chase I'm out
looking for my people seven of them to
be exact
they've been gone a long while and I'm
worried they might have gotten lost
maybe you've seen him [ __ ] it's that
Carver an old man Spanish guy and his
daughter quiet girl bit taller than you
big black guy this big in a pretty
little pregnant lady I saw them they're
dead you saw who we're down by the river
the other day who walkers got him I'm
sorry the river you sure about that
pretty sure yeah well no offense but I
guess that wasn't them
cuz the ones I'm looking for are very
careful
if you say so the [ __ ] does a bad dad
that's a bad there's [ __ ] what are you
doing don't I just get the gun count
that looks like a damn tornado ran
through here must be like close to ten
people with you tonight has a knife
that's a real nice place kind of cozy
can't kill this [ __ ] it asses too tight
of a [ __ ] but a smart man I miss him I
don't care yes yes this is my house
fair point
well whites in trouble what the [ __ ] is
wrong with this guy
three moves away from checkmate Sam it
nothing nobody's here nobody is here
great we're gonna kill this guy you
gotta kill this guy though so then you
gotta kill this [ __ ] I told you
nobody's here
seems that way didn't mean to be rude
couldn't just leave you here with a good
conscience if someone was poking around
right sure
who's this must be someone who lived
here must be set you have no idea who
these people are do you I don't know
what you're talking about let me ask you
this when you met him how much did they
trust you I think it's a [ __ ]
well I think I've troubled you long
enough I can let myself out yeah thank
God
Clementine Sarah they told me about Pete
you know where he is right come on let's
go
what what did she say someone came to
the cabin
what Clementine talk to him and you just
opened the door for him calm down
Rebecca calm down I am calm you calm
down I didn't open the door he just came
in she's telling the truth did he say
his name did he say what his name was
yeah it wasn't
I didn't ask his name
you didn't ask his name how could you
not ask your name he had a gun I didn't
want to make him mad yeah Clem just tell
us what he looked like
what was he wearing did he sound
different how old was he he had a big
brown coat did have a lining a collar
yeah sure
he talked about you dad you're not gonna
hurt anyone are you
of course he won't Sara your dad's a
nicest man I know which is why he's not
gonna do anything crazy or not nice
right look at you know these are bad
people sweetie
they will do or say anything to hurt us
now what do you think it seemed like
you'd be coming back a picture what were
you doing taking pictures Carlos what
you need to calm down all right you're
scaring your daughter
I'm gonna say [ __ ] lucky he wasn't
expecting to find us Clementine must
have surprised him she hadn't been there
well guess who's smart to stick around
but he'll be back with the rest we don't
have much time he's right everyone pack
up we're moving out Alvin wait to leave
now sweetie before he comes back with
more bad guys it's gonna be okay let's
just go get your things
what does he want to bring us back Clem
I don't know what he told you but
William Carver is a dangerous Carver
he's the leader of a camp not far from
here and he's very smart
we were lucky to escape look I'm sorry
to involve you but now that he's seen
you you'll be safer with us we have to
leave okay we have to find Pete we'll
get him on the way out Nick Clementine
you know where he was right yeah
all right everybody grab your stuff
let's hit the road
oh great hello rash right there you said
it was just up here sorry if I gave you
some [ __ ] back there just a little [ __ ]
but I'm trying Claire I know you did
your best back there you know none of us
would make it on our own
I'm gonna rock this bench I want to push
her down the scenario there Paula
coathangers a pile of coat hangers okay
there that's where we were
he's not in here the last place I saw
him this city tell about how he was like
devoured but they liked looking for him
[ __ ] all right
he's a rock now Jesus I see blood I want
you to tell people were [ __ ] just
following it all right okay I don't
think he's gonna make it
I think he's gonna make it
what happened what the hell happens he's
been shot he just said that probably the
white man well I may have taken our land
when honestly I'm like the best gamer of
all time that was Pete I'm sorry
it's Christmas dad glad to have you
she's like either dead or a sex slave
well they'll get their 5 days to reach
those mountains now if they're tracking
us we should be able to lose them up
there ok it's gonna be ok but you have
to keep moving now it's our only choice
ok
five days later Oh God it's a [ __ ] it
looks like our new homes a bridge and
vanish still and he's still moping yeah
big dirty what's it look like
building sounds like a good place to
spend the night Geralyn must be that ski
resort what else is there it's pretty
small what else is here who else is here
yeah yeah good
we have to cross that bridge let's go
hold on now
okay I'll go sprinting across that thing
okay we get spotted out there we're
gonna be trapped going around that Lake
will take too long right we've got no
idea who's out there
okay I'm gonna sneak across make sure
it's clear before you bring the whole
group over in this case yes but it's
better than risk and everyone at once
what's your plan Clement I can scoot
across low and slow make sure nobody's
waiting for us on the other side hey
thanks for signing me up you know I
appreciate that I guess thanks for
including me but dangerous I can do it
see no problem it's gonna be fine
they will sing you guys in ten minutes
just watch for a light at far side I can
go too
you stay with the group I'm fine Luke I
don't like this
yeah well when's the last time you liked
anything Carlos if something happens
I'll cover you come on but why are they
gonna stand out Nick hey sorry about
that let's just could really use your
eyes and right now I don't trust Nick to
tie his own shoes you're just still on
edge after the Carver thing oh my god is
that Carver's baby in this world
babies what does everyone want family
it's a tough world out there without
people you can trust
plenty why see
we've all made I wash I tell you about
it [ __ ] yoga people you know Oh a
young outdoors let's take a look at some
I'll [ __ ] psychopath look weapon you
know okay I know I've done this before
remember in a shed yeah he's like [ __ ]
nice work kid you just hit a child he's
smiling that's been pretty for a branch
oh great this [ __ ] did there's so
slow I afraid take those two together
guys oh [ __ ] [ __ ] dick I still alive
oh [ __ ] kill kill kill that [ __ ] let's
miss that one push over push over get it
get it
Oh show me like searching
well I did amazing they should give me
more money for what I have done you know
if it was that pregnant lady she fought
and now they're over by now hitting
rocks on the way without us you're not
pregnant
Oh Oh a single Walker ooh better run I
said walking [ __ ] it's killer just play
it cool and you did the dog I don't want
to get in a fight you really think you
two a little girl just don't make any
sudden moves and don't piss him off
and don't tell him anything didn't know
one second thought maybe I should do the
talking
well who are you who's askin
oh um I'm Clementine and this is Luc
Clementine and Luc
yes them okay we gotta kill oh you don't
look like [ __ ] are you [ __ ] no
offense or anything but you know how it
is out here we're just people fair
enough
you folks headed north like everyone
else everyone else I see at least one
group a day moved through here you know
look the same
have you seen someone named Krista
Krista baby really no I mean a lot of
people come through here I don't know I
gotta say you two look like [ __ ] if you
need food I've got some canned stuff
well if I have food I would never give
it yes sir awful nice EU what's the
catch no catch I've got plenty
all right there thank you ain't no
problem nice running into friendly faces
out here like I said I've got food and
supplies back in the station and if you
Warren
what the [ __ ] man
the hell is he doing what the [ __ ]
finally Nick that's up and right
did I hit him where is he I told you not
to shoot what who was that guy he was
going to help us how do you know damn it
I told you not to shoot how was I
supposed to hear you you gave me a clear
shot that shot rang out for miles you
gotta get off this bridge let's go hey
Nick is [ __ ] out we gotta put him down
we gotta put him down like seriously
that's not what it looked like to me
everybody calm down what did you see
Quinn he wasn't gonna do anything I know
what I saw
either way you could have hit one of us
yeah but I didn't look I know Pete was
close to you Nick but you don't [ __ ]
talk about him
you think he was with Carver I don't
know I we have to keep moving
I can't wait a minute fine
look can I talk to you alone okay hey
Clem you got anything
dying here Alvin I told you I'm fine now
for that [ __ ] which we still have those
juice boxes am i checking it out maybe
we can spend the night here sure thanks
Club okay you talk to me talk to Nick
Nick how about
now he put the makeup on to Jesus
sounds weird when I said although no but
if I just don't say anything have you so
pissed off Luke always used to push me I
never wanted to go into business with it
I remember when he sold me on his big
plan some [ __ ] plan case of beer and
he just said Nick we're burning daylight
that was that after six months we were
flat broke I ain't care we were having
fun mm-hmm I wish I was like him I wish
I could just keep moving all the time
I'm just not built like that okay I'm
glad you came to terms with that I swear
it looked like he was holding you guys
up I figured he was with Carver he could
have been anybody right we don't know no
he wasn't our ver anyway anyway no that
was in front of me he takes that shot
maybe I am losing it I don't know
anymore
I'm hungry what time is it anyway
yeah no no [ __ ] hell
what's wrong I left my watch back at the
cabin
it was Pete's he gave it to me it's all
I had left you know what I'm gonna go
talk to them yeah okay
hey check around this side real quick oh
I see cams it's really small Jesus is
there a ghost in here is there a ghost
in here empty cans
well [ __ ] [ __ ]
you take the survival knife though Oh W
at Westminster here's her dog show
okay gettin pretty good [ __ ] that job
but you know clementines pretty cool so
I can't say anything
it's dead okay good he chased that knife
on here come on a cone yep like you kill
kill kill kill when you love those kids
yeah - can't afford me and look man I
thought we had a bed look at this dump I
was actually gonna get food me only two
cancer's lost a lot of his people that's
for sure that doesn't give him any
excuse to start shooting up strangers he
was to help us yeah and someone died
ain't no judge but that straight-up
murder in my book
yeah we're next gonna be a problem
something's gotta be done we gotta kill
peaches I love me some peaches
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] after that disgusting
well she's eating for two
you think we can keep this just between
us I hate to even say you know but and I
never go against the group but I've got
to put back in the baby first you
understand right the whole group should
decide Nick was a good guy he's still a
good guy he's just lose that dad knows
we're not perfect hell I'm glad you're
with us Clementine what
walkers we got a problem here yeah all
right we're heading up how they [ __ ]
across the bridge so easily you fall in
our holes and [ __ ] then I walked up
slopes of a [ __ ] suck I hate this
[ __ ] suck I'll go with you well be good
to know if anybody's actually back there
probably get a better view from up top
easier time getting up there you feel
like taking a look yeah sure just like
climbing a tree house anyone following
us how will we know it's done we'll know
okay I'll be a monkey
just take it slow and I'll catch you if
you fall probable it's a lighter slip
and I gotta press Q or some [ __ ] [ __ ]
water
[Music]
well pretty cool view up here Wow
really nice landscape it get away from
here bird yeah you doing here oh wait
sorry this one for your house [ __ ]
Hobart now only look for the good stuff
the secret stuff Dave oh [ __ ] there they
are some are there oh [ __ ] people have
guns down there they're aiming at them
this is [ __ ] up oh [ __ ]
hi excuse me honey but do I look like a
[ __ ] thief yes Sarah
get behind me tell us who you are we
ain't here to rob nobody put the gun
down
my dad whoa whoa whoa please oh my god
you know this guy Kenny I'll take that
as a yes Wow
we can talk inside great I just started
there
thank God Kenny I'm happy Wow it's
looking good these days he was like my
only but you know who's going apeshit
you know what happened to him [ __ ] can I
have it they're happy here Jenny and
Sarita have been staying with us for
several weeks used to be a ski lodge
obviously so we have plenty of food and
believe it or not we still get some
power from that wind turbine out front
we tend to keep most of the lights off
at night to avoid drawing attention but
after we found this stuff in storage we
couldn't resist making an exception
what's funny Oh Walter here's one smart
sumbitch makes a mean can of beans -
this is insane what a setup
he's that kind of charge my phone the
people you were the one waving the gun
around man
dad look Sara the [ __ ] pick up the gun
pick up the gun maybe so funny well
Kenny is overjoyed that one car Burgos
the dork finds all the weapons wow what
a setup did what I set out still wearing
this dirty old thing you know I half
expected to surely walk up next to you
you guys were like two peas in a pod
oh [ __ ] I didn't mean to I knew would
fire can't remember what happens dude oh
yeah it was duck [ __ ]
so where'd you end up [ __ ] Krista and
Omid Omid well Krista and I were
together this [ __ ] these guys caught us
she's gone sounds like it ain't been
easy for you I'm sorry darlin
I wish I could have found you sooner hmm
but everything's gonna be fine now where
have you been
oh hell all over after Savannah how did
you get out of there
Krista got in a hell of a mess I gave
her a hand and then it got Messier for a
minute there it wasn't looking too good
for old Kenny
long story short no shad look II really
spent a long time alone after that
and then I met Sarita thank God
gosh it's great to have you back you too
catching up Clem this is my girl
Sarita ain't she beautiful nice to meet
you Clementine hey whoa where's Matthew
he's still out there rooting around of
course he is
well I'll start dinner Carlos right mind
if I steal your daughter for a secret
mission stay in sight sweetie can we do
anything to help could use a hand
outside we've got a lot of supplies to
bring in before that storm hits
sure why don't you really sick didn't he
like jump into a [ __ ] pit I think
that's what he did in the very end how
do you [ __ ] live yeah thanks
excellent wanna help me prepare a little
dinner so how do you know Kenny he and
Sarita had been a huge help
we're old friends I met him after it
happened when he was with Leif yeah he
only told us a little well huh
connecting with people is so important I
don't know what I'd do without Matthew
just rather gosh you remind me of my
students I can't imagine what it's like
growing up in the middle of all this
it hasn't been easy
[Music]
he makes the best beans was you gonna
dump the boiling boil shut my face
[Music]
what two beans well then what you sayin
that [ __ ] look around the watch and now
let me see this [ __ ] [ __ ]
she hates it I know she does see here a
little radio package it's gonna make too
much noise in a table dad get ya tray
like this [ __ ]
[Music]
clam we could use some help here Sara
you take this and string them up over
there you know candy before it must be
incredible to see him again
yeah but hold up you should have seen
this beard then perfect now we just need
the chopper we always had an angel on
top of our tree my family didn't
celebrate Christmas but I still loved
the decorations
what a tree topper okay let's see here
let's see here a tree toppers over here
look this wrapper work are we [ __ ]
there are we not [ __ ] they're [ __ ]
okay let's see here I are not a couple
okay oh it's a Carver shows up you know
I can't scantly a good time [ __ ] you
can't walk that way I can't walk this
way you [ __ ] a I guess I'm going all
the way around go faster Valentine a lot
faster sign I think it's to go up there
can be sure it's been a week man we
gotta be out of the woods but can be
sure they might be tracking us tracking
what do you think yeah [ __ ] others did
people way down there huh I saw lights
which way did they go through the woods
we cannot take any chances we leave at
dawn but we're safe here for tonight
right right What did he say
he mentioned someone else someone else
ooh
his friend his name is Matthew look I
don't care what that man said we stand
here tonight just talk to the rest of
them they trust you see what you can
find out I'm gonna go find Luke I'm
gonna go find Luke yeah you got I'll be
right back I wanna rock this [ __ ] I
hate this [ __ ] I hate is there a tree
top right good
backing out right now oh [ __ ] okay [ __ ]
all right beautiful
this time of year you know now that your
friends are here this place is starting
to feel like a real home Matthew and
Walter yes yes yes I agree wait until
you meet Matthew he's a real character
the first time he met me he called me
Rita where is Matthew oh he likes to go
on long walks he didn't Walter used to
vacation here he should be back soon
good um I wanted to ask you does Kenny
seem different to you I didn't know him
before and well I'm curious he has good
days and bad days
he's like everyone else he seems like
the same old Kenny to me well that's
good busy yeah she's awful
why don't you go see if your friends are
ready for dinner Clementine again I want
to [ __ ] that [ __ ] up upstairs real
quick I'm gonna [ __ ] her up so I can
hate this [ __ ] I [ __ ] hate this
[ __ ] I'm gonna make her angry I can't
even take care of myself
how am I supposed to raise a child I
mean how can anyone now everything so
[ __ ] up it's not gonna be easy
Thanks I already because I know that no
matter what happens I'll get to meet
someone new she's kicking No
what you done that's how I can't believe
I'm asking the little girl for tonight
but I guess nothing's weird anymore he
won't kill you he was my man just need
to get some fooling I'm gonna tell him
I'm gonna tell him this [ __ ] before he
gives her all the fit I'm just trying to
forget about it right here clamp this
[ __ ] and like I sit with ya kanays then
that case I was gonna staple that's fun
so what's the deal with your friend here
yes you're just talking about this
Kinney what do you make of them clinton
see good guy
I trust him with your life yeah
Walter was telling me his family died
[Music]
yeah yeah it is he lost this whole thing
wife and kid lost it have drinks oh well
hey there hey hope you like the food
oh it's it's great thank you beaches and
beans right for nutrition not too great
on the way out though I tell you okay so
it's Luke and Luke and Nick you guys
sure do look like a match what's that
supposed to mean
I'm just saying you look like good
friends that's all so what was your plan
here vote out for the winner actually we
were thinking of moving on somewhere up
north you ever heard of a place called
Wellington Wellington the hell is that a
place what kind of place yeah it's in
the North supposed to be a big camp up
near Mission Chef Michigan you got a
hearing problem kid yeah Michigan oh my
god freshwater lots of land and cold ass
winter so the walkers gets lost sounds
like [ __ ]
listen vanilla ice I don't know what
your deal is but you're more
welcome to take off in the more that be
just fine by me what's the deal with
these guys clan [ __ ] you buddy
it's fine we're not steady she's staying
excuse me Luke listen to him I have been
Kenny's my friend oh [ __ ] there's no
need for this now look we've all had a
long [ __ ] up ask me that can duck Duck
Duck I think I say [ __ ] it's not my
right to say hey Clementine would you
lend me a hand outside for a moment
I'm sorry about that now I used to be a
teacher and I remember what it's like to
be caught in the middle of to class up
with those guys gonna wear it it may
take a little time but that's just how
these things work everything will be
fine
listen relationships are like any
machine you don't throw them out when
they break down we're gonna leave in the
morning
no no we have to keep moving Clementine
in this world you don't have to do
anything well huh they say the world is
over but I'll tell you a secret it's not
people are more political mouth and they
ever were before in the end we can't
change them all we can do is continue to
learn from each other to empathize and
use our heads all war is a symptom of
man's failures thinking Steinbeck have
you read them we gotta get the [ __ ] out
of here
there's like a [ __ ] cab after us okay
[ __ ] is the man he just walked all day I
should be like a pig forgot what he says
I just said all right
you can talk to a client there's almost
nothing you could tell me that would
surprise me I can promise you that I'm
just worried about the people chasing us
here safely
don't worry Matthew will be back soon
and everything will be fine
hey kids what are you two talking about
Oh politics the hell not being from
Florida I would imagine you know all
about politics Kenny I was just gonna
check the windows around back before
this storm hits give his hand [ __ ] Oh oh
my god
killer I'm Emma Bonnie it's fine we
don't know that like [ __ ] 50 yeah you
don't have to do that no no it's fine
what about your people
we've got plenty you stay put I'll be
right back
she's the one that been 400 days that
like cheated on that guy I that like got
hurt his leg wife killed [ __ ] I'm just
not gonna talk to this [ __ ] [ __ ]
supplies yeah they [ __ ] gave all the
food away what the [ __ ] walk little nuts
we gotta get rid of Walt don't freak out
[ __ ] [ __ ] the bridge was Baltar's friend
oh [ __ ] that's not about their friend
now they're all worried he's not back
yet
walking hey oh my god okay we're gonna
keep this secret okay okay good now that
knife because if it was Matthews and
Walter sees it he's gonna put two and
two together it's with the other weapons
oh okay they'll get rid of it now find
Walter and run interference
oh and keep an eye out for Nick I'm
right here
what's up god this [ __ ] [ __ ]
there's nothing and I just wanted it
check and see if you're okay
you told me to tuck me in yeah yeah hey
if there's something going on I want to
know no just go back to bed Nick I'm
serious all right let's show the photos
you can talk to me okay kiss me
Jesus cuz I don't
I'm sure no because I don't want to
accidentally say that like I killed it
right now we gotta kill I can't live
with that on me right you can't tell it
listen to her okay it's [ __ ] crazy
Jesus I can't handle this look just go
do that thing alright okay good where is
it
is it missing oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
are you okay I always like this
gave it to Matthew when all this started
oh my god who did it
was it the kid what's his name Nick
heard him talking earlier or something
about shooting a man
found it putting it /ak
this is Nick a good man or is he just
like everyone else he is he's a good guy
Walter
look
he was always doing I told him something
oh my god what the [ __ ]
tell me what you did just tell me
something tell me what happened from a
distance it looked like anyone I thought
he was gonna shoot my friends and I oh
oh
what the [ __ ] is gonna happen I have no
[ __ ] idea
well what's going on
stornes got it spinning out of control
that sounds good to draw walkers we
gotta shut it down now they help me
carry the guns
I loved when Kenny is like saying like
that's a damn but why and I like it
[ __ ] she just get it [ __ ] crazy turn
this thing off first dude
sure they go right into Carver
does anyone know how to do this no it
does I'm a doctor she know how to do it
but a yellow yellow engineer okay
can't see [ __ ] okay take this k okay put
the key in the keyhole okay and I'm no
engineer but Wow okay that's how my eye
like crack I hacked it oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh no arms is here maybe back to Lodge
Lodge Lodge I have practice with [ __ ]
miss Cheerilee an accident you know so I
can pick up checksum on brother Warcraft
sir arrest
g'day mate g'day hey gone mate
hey gun oh nice jeans um let's attack
this guy yeah yeah
let's take out these [ __ ] all right
yeah good just want to take two shots
and I reload
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh it's gonna get
though the guns like hidden junkie some
rabbits lose the guns right there get it
kill kill kill kill kill kill ticka
ticka ticka ticka gimme yeah okay what
the [ __ ] is she strong
now this makes it easy oh yeah it's only
like chachi oh [ __ ]
some are oh that man I just don't trust
oh I just don't trust oh [ __ ] Kenny's
missing out now is the chance to tell
this guy that it's not her kid [ __ ] air
comes Carver's gang [ __ ] [ __ ] I [ __ ]
hate this [ __ ] oh [ __ ] that's Carver's
kid
yes I this is [ __ ] up this is [ __ ]
up this is not good
this is this is like panties wet not
good like panties worth doing math tests
not good [ __ ] [ __ ] we gotta kill one by
one that looks like a [ __ ] alien
go go go man how the [ __ ] are we gonna
cover these guys and look for them to
Johnny cover that window
we gonna kill these [ __ ] I know I
guess I've been out the herd to make
characters on this episode you know I
get too many episodes in the season they
suck tell people OFF the baby you need a
doctor you of
[Music]
[Music]
lurking Kanak well they always
yeah it's like that I get there thank
you
[ __ ] hurry
clam
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] gave up
[ __ ] yeah we can damn straight
good guys get get literally needed have
use those give them all your food I know
shitty shot I'm gonna March another one
of your friends out here he's the [ __ ]
man
just take it so I could take it you
Kenny can't you're a [ __ ] man [ __ ]
[ __ ] Sarita he's like she gonna kill
Sarita no way
kill him kill that [ __ ] no no no you
[ __ ] [ __ ] Clem drop the gun
where's Luke finally run come on Lu
[Music]
ah [ __ ] Chet Chet Chet all right well
that's the episode for you let's see
what's happening next let's see what's
happening next look good can two [ __ ]
men let's remember these are our
brothers and sisters and they all have a
vital role to play in this community
they strayed from the flock yeah that
don't mean they can't earn their way
back into the fold I don't mean we can't
find it in our hearts to forgive them
no one full well those who choose not to
accept our love surely wish they had
shed the story
oh [ __ ] looks like a good a Mossad okay
well I'll stay tuned okay I am yeah the
plates will discuss bet again if you sit
with dinner sounds good okay I'm sorry
till Walter true that Matthew I did tell
the truth
next faint yeah convince my officers
forget neck yeah left to find Kenny yes
yes
jacket alright guys that's all for now
bye